We have seen that
under some conditions,
the binomial PMF is well
approximated by a Poisson PMF.
But we have also seen
the central limit theorem
that tells us that the binomial
PMF can be approximated
using a normal random variable.
Can we reconcile
these two facts?
Let's look into the situation
in some more detail.
Consider a Poisson process
that has rate equal to 1.
And consider that
Poisson process
running over the
unit time interval.
We take the unit
interval, and we split it
into many small
sub-intervals, where
each sub-interval
has a length of 1/n.
And let Xi be the number of
arrivals that we get during
the i'th interval.
Xi is a Poisson random variable.
And the mean of that
random variable,
or the parameter of
that random variable,
is just the duration of the time
interval, since the rate is 1.
So it's a Poisson random
variable, with parameter 1/n.
Now, let us look at the
total number of arrivals.
The total number of arrivals
is the sum of how many arrivals
we had during each one
of these intervals.
And we know the
distribution of S. S
is a Poisson random variable,
with parameter equal to 1.
Now, here what we have is
a sum of random variables
that are independent and
identically distributed.
They are identically
distributed,
because all of these intervals
have the same length.
And they're independent,
because in the Poisson process,
what happens in
different intervals are
independent events.
So we are in a
situation where we
could apply the
central limit theorem.
We have a sum of
many independent,
identically distributed
random variables.
And by letting n go to infinity,
the central limit theorem
appears to tell us that
S is going to be normal.
Now, how can we reconcile
these two facts?
We know that the Poisson
distribution is not the same
as a normal distribution.
What is the catch?
Well, the catch
is the following--
the central limit theorem
applies to a situation where we
fix a certain
probability distribution,
the distribution of the Xi's.
And it tells us that as we add
more and more of these Xi's,
asymptotically, we obtain
a distribution that's
well approximated by a normal.
On the other hand, what we have
here is actually different.
The Xi's do not have
a fixed distribution.
But rather, the distribution
of Xi depends on n.
That is, if we change
n so that we're
adding more random
variables, we're
variables that are now
coming from a
different distribution.
And this is not a situation
to which the central limit
theorem applies.
And therefore, this conclusion
here is not justified.
And so there's no
contradiction between the two
types of approximations.
To summarize, the
situation is as follows.
Consider a binomial random
variable with some parameters
n and p.
Now, let p be fixed.
And let n go to infinity.
In that case, the
binomial random variable
can be thought of as the sum of
n Bernoulli random variables.
And those Bernoulli
random variables
have a parameter
p, which is fixed.
So we're dealing with the
sum of iid random variables
from a fixed distribution.
And this is the situation
where the central limit
theorem applies.
And we have a normal
approximation.
On the other hand, if
we take the product
n times p, which is the
expected value of this binomial,
to stay constant,
but we let n go
to infinity and at the same
time let p go to 0, then
in this regime, in the
limit, this random variable
will be well approximated by
a Poisson random variable.
So we have two different
approximations.
Both of them are
valid, but they're
valid in different regimes.
Now, although they're
different, there's
actually an interesting case in
which the two will not really
differ.
And this is the following.
Consider a Poisson random
variable with parameter n.
And we're interested in the
limit as n goes to infinity.
We can think of
this random variable
as the number of arrivals
during an interval
of length n in a Poisson process
with arrival rate equal to 1.
Now, let's take this
interval and split it
into n intervals, each of
which has a length of 1.
And let us call Xi the number of
arrivals in the i'th interval.
Our Poisson random variable
is going to be, of course,
equal to the sum of
the number of arrivals
during each one
of the intervals.
Each one of these
random variables
is Poisson with
parameter equal to 1.
And these random variables
are actually iid.
Now, what's happening
in this case
is that even when we
increase n, because we're
using constant length intervals,
the distribution of the Xi's
doesn't change.
So this is a situation
in which we're
going to get approximately a
normal random variable as n
goes to infinity.
So what we see is that a
Poisson random variable, but
with a very large
parameter, starts
to approach the
normal distribution.
And this in particular
will tell us
that these two approximations
that we have, in some regime,
they would start to agree.
Now, all of this discussion
here has been asymptotic.
We talk about p going to
0 or n going to infinity.
But in any real situation, you
will be given actual numbers.
And you cannot really tell,
is this number close to 0,
or is it not?
Here, we need some rules of
thumb or maybe some experience.
Let's look at some examples.
In this case, n times
p is equal to 1.
So the number of
arrivals or the values
of the binomial random variable
will take values 0, 1, 2,
3, but with high probability,
not a lot more than that.
So the binomial random
variable is really
a discrete random variable.
There's no way to
approximate it with a normal.
On the other hand,
p is very small.
So a Poisson
approximation would be
very reasonable
in this situation.
On the other hand, if
p is equal to 1/3, then
definitely 1/3 is
not a small number.
A Poisson approximation
would not apply.
But n is pretty big.
So that a normal approximation
would be appropriate.
And finally, in this case,
we would obtain a Poisson
approximation with parameter
100, because n times p is 100.
But a Poisson random
variable with parameter 100
is also well
approximated by a normal.
Or to think about
it differently,
we start with a Bernoulli
distribution that's
very skewed, [the] probability
of success is just 100.
And this makes it difficult
for the central limit theorem
to apply when you start with a
very asymmetric distribution.
On the other hand, because
we're adding so many of them,
the central limit theorem
actually does take hold.
And so this is an example
where both approximations
will be valid.
So finally, to conclude, we have
two different approximations.
They're valid in
different regimes.
And in practice, you
need to do some thinking
before deciding to choose one
versus the other approximation.